you know service doesn't have to be some  some big thing um um it's it starts with  your friends  you know um uh service and leadership  are very very similar things and  the way i like to define leadership is  it's a responsibility to see those  around us rise  do your friends feel that someone has  their back do your friends feel  seen do your friends feel heard do your  friends feel understood  are you practicing the skill of empathy  and and listening  do you know how to have an effective  confrontation when you have a  disagreement with a friend  um and all of these skills um  make your friends feel valued and  valuable in in your life which builds  their own self-confidence and helps them  go do bigger things  so um as much as i also love  service when you serve your community  and go do those things it really does  start at home it starts with your  friends and it starts with your family  it's and it's a great place to practice  because you get immediate feedback  you